hello everyone and just in case you're
wondering I will not be blundering the
sound this video since all of you are
commenting on my butt on me blundering
the sound all the time I I was really
careful not to do it this time and
someone said in the comments that I
should use my favourite snacks - you
know reward myself every time I don't
wander a sound and then I thought yeah
that'd be a really good idea but then
I'm constantly thinking about the snacks
and I'm probably not ever gonna blunder
the sound anymore
but we'll see you know you never know so
this is another interesting game from
around 11 of the 2013 candidates
tournament it's what made romic vs. team
or raja baath and before we check out
the game we do have a couple of photos -
to be exact here is a nice close-up of
Vladimir Kramnik nothing nothing out of
the ordinary with this photo and here we
have a follow a couple of moves from the
opening were played kramnik on only
playing with points so far a very
interesting variation as you'll see in
the game so let's see the game and the
quote about the book the quote above the
board sons this game up pretty nicely
but there is a lot of poison to it as
you'll see so Cromley has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 c4 g6 and g3 c5 Knight to
f3 and Bishop to g7 so we have the Kings
Indian defense something called the
pterodactyl defense Bishop to G to C
captures on d4 Knight captures Sun
before and a job of castles Knight to c3
into c7 now attacking the c4 pawn and b3
now an interesting variation Kramnik
prepared again cronic says that as usual
you can check out the interview about
this game after you watch the video
there will be a link in the description
below as usual the center idea is nice
the d5 actually were black can't really
capture on c4 because now white is
attacking the e7 point and the exchange
in the center will definitely favor
white after knife captures then C pawn
becomes a D pawn and a deep one is
always better than a C pawn most of the
times so after Queen to see 7v3 a nice
prepared line by Vladimir Kramnik we
have d5 Knight d2 b5 attacking the Queen
Queen to a5 pinning the c3 Knight and
Bishop to d2 you don't want to allow any
anywhere discoveries here so first D
captures on c4 nice to defy Knight to e5
doesn't really work now because when the
c4 pawn was captured the beat the b5
Knight is no longer defended so no
tactics are possible here so first B
captors on c4 and now some nasty
discoveries are definitely possible
Solar Java brings back the Queen Queen
to d8 we have castles and a6 now
knife to a3 and are a lot of the night
is on the rim of course you never want
to have that but there are some nice
ideas about this night in the future the
knight can come into the game back via
c2 and and III or maybe maybe maybe
white can even push this C pawn playing
Knight c4 and then maybe create an
outpost for this Knight and b6 after
Bishop to e3 is played so definitely not
not a useless Knight Bishop to a5 as the
bishop now came to a five now Knights e2
to e3 is definitely a more preferred
option this night will be attacking the
bishop so night the C - we have Knight
to c6 and night to e3 and here what do
you do here your Bishop is under attack
to remove the bishop to defend the
bishop do you want to give up the bishop
pair should you should you give up the
bishop pair at the engine actually
prefers Queen to b4 here simply
attacking the c4 pawn and the engine
doesn't care about ruining the pawn
structure here and opening up the King
side as there is a really no way for a
white to take advantage of this but you
know if you're not prepared you know
chromic is prepared chronic is playing
this game without wasting any time you
don't want to allow something like this
so our job was for Queen to d7
we have knife captors on high five Queen
captures on i-5 now the structure is you
know solid nothing is ruined and rook to
be one here chronic attacks the b7 pawn
rook a to d8 now
very nice idea the bishop is pinned of
course you can't move the bishop because
you lose the Queen so can you capture
the b7 pawn you can capture it but it
doesn't really give you all that much if
you play rook captures on b7
then you get nice to a5 the rook is
under attack then the knight is also
attacking the c4 pawn and you definitely
don't want to allow Knight captures on
c4 then the knight and the rook will be
attacking the bishop so after Luke
defense then you have to worry about
ideas like Queen to c5 attacking the
rook and now with a double attack on the
c4 pawn and now you have to find a move
for wide that is nice - d5 and now now
it's a it's a very nice idea after
Knight captures on c4 Queen to c2 pins
the night and after Knight captures rook
captures on c4 it will be it will be a
better position for white as the bishop
pair will have an easier game but you
know such complications are you don't
want to calculate something like this
you'll easily miss it and it's a very
longer variation and cronic isn't
interested he first plays Queen to see
one and only now if job allows it he
will he will capture first we have a
queen to e6 so maybe maybe given up the
b7 pawn for the c4 pawn and kinda not
allowing this nice to move as the knight
has to protect de to pawn Knight to d5
would be a very nice idea for white but
then d2 pawn will fall so first chronic
plays rook to e1 defense d2 pawn and now
we have Queen captures on c4 rook
captures on b7 finally Kramnik grabs
that pawn Knight to e5 and here we have
Bishop to f4 chromic isn't interested in
capturing d7 point it's a pawn sacrifice
biter job of it's hard to say after rook
captures
hard to say what his idea was probably
probably to simply activate all of his
pieces after loop character's captures
but it's hard to say if this is
compensation enough for a pawn in a
practical game probably yes it's a
strong Bishop on g7
the daruka rockin queen are placed very
nicely the nights are very active so in
a practical game probably as Kramnik
decided not to capture these seven phone
so after Knight to e5 we have Bishop to
f4 queen back to e6 now defending these
seven pawn we have a ch3 g4 is a very
important square the guard as both
Knights are eyeing that square we have
knife to c4 and now comes a e4 Knight
back to e5 Bishop captures on e5 Queen
captures on e5 and now Knight to d5 you
could go for Knight captures but after
Knight captures pawn captures that's
that's really nothing for black here you
have to move the Queen both of the rooks
are attacking now d7 pawn so nothing for
you there
so after 95 rook to e8 at a defending b7
pawn nice to be four now attacking the a
sex bomb we have rook to the seven
offering a trade of rooks nice to see
six now attacking the Queen Queen to e6
and rook to b6 now by Kramnik and this
is a very interesting moment in the game
you know not a lot of discoveries are
possible at the moment because the rook
on d6 is undefended but you know the
rook is x-raying that Queen on e6 and
also attacking the pawn erasing so what
do you do here
here are a job of amidst a very nice
opportunity to go to go for rook to c7
pinning that night as the queen is in c1
and here you have to give up the pawn
rook captures an a6 and then knife to d7
go for Knights to b8 at the pile up on
this pin c6 Knight which is kind of
interesting because this Knight is
preventing this route from capturing
this Queen and this route from capturing
this Queen so it's a very complicated
position but every five now the bishop
is also protecting the knight Knight
captures on e5 and Queen to d1 now
unpinning the night still cannot capture
here because now this knight is pinned
from this rook rook eat the c8 doubling
up on this night and now this was the
idea you had to see that
black was now completely fine that
for is not possible because of Queen to
see for attacking the undefended rook
and a six and after Knight to e7
attacking the rook and c8 Queen captures
Knight captures knife to c6 now getting
the night away from me five Bishop
captures Queen captures now the night is
attacked
now comes the night captures on e7 rook
captures only seven and now we have to
see that if you capture with the rook
then Queen c5 check will win back the
rope so after Queen to d8 check Bishop
to f8 now comes rope captures and now of
course Queen to see five kingdoms and
Queen captures and the black will be up
a piece so a very nice idea on this rope
to c7 move here after rope to b6 rook to
c7 definitely playable for black but our
Java was very low on time he was
struggling with chronic spared variation
and perhaps he did not want to invest
time in calculating rope the c7 so
instead he played rook captures and the
Queen captures an a2 if you can grab a
pawn and there's nothing wrong with it
you definitely should
but unfortunately for a job oh there is
something wrong with it here if I was
played now the knight of course is under
attack
we have Knight to d5 and try to find the
idea here what was what was chronics
idea in this position so feel free to
pause the video and you know punish her
job of for for his insolence I'm
grabbing the a to pawn so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you're an excellent
Punisher and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show here chromic played
rope to be - and now it's very
interesting what do you do with the
Queen there are not not a lot of squares
you can go to I 5 is covered by the
Queen the only square available to the
Queen is Queen to a4 which was played in
the game you have to see that moves like
Queen 283 don't work for a very specific
idea the idea Queen a3 doesn't work and
that this is a something you had to see
if you actually found
chronics route to be to that now rook to
b8 will win you the game now of course
your queen is under attack
and the rukon yet is under attack if
black captures rook then you lose the
Queen and if Queen captures first you
will capture the rope with check and
after Bishop blocks only then will you
recapture the Queen and you will be up a
whole rook so after work to be two you
have to go Queen to a four and now comes
bestial capture Sundy five rock after
Sun d5 and now now comes Rock two before
once again attacking the Queen again the
only square available for the Queen is a
two and now comes the move you also have
to see I really hope you were able to do
this Knight captures on e7 with check
and now it's a very nice fork the King
is under attack
also the rook on d5 will fall if you
capture then comes the Queen to c8 you
have to block this and now comes Rock
the b8 and there's really no defense
against Queen captures and I faith this
is this is game over
so after this Knight to e7 check a king
to h8 was played and now comes some
Knight captures on d5 we have Queen
captures and now the immediate Queen to
c4 Kramnik just won the exchange and
without any any further ado he wants to
exchange Queens and win the game Queen
captures on c4 there really isn't a
better move here for the job and he
still didn't reach time control five
more moves until time control rook
captures on c4 and Bishop captures on e5
so for the exchange a job of is is up a
pawn but not not for long
here chronic play King to f1 and it was
in this position that Timur at a job of
resigned the game why did he resign rook
to e4 were immediate it was also
possible but chronic first ones is king
and a nice light square as a reserve of
does have a dark square Bishop so there
are you know no mistakes even possible
to make he resign because now of course
f4 is a terrible threat you will either
lose the bishop or the rook and after
something like rook to e6 f4 you move
simply exchange rooks and then you will
start gobbling up those those pawns and
of course a rook will always beat a
bishop most of the times so yeah after
this like we've said
King to f1 move our joggle resigned the
game and are very nice and a very
important victory for Vladimir Kramnik
in this tournament so before I forget we
should definitely check out the
standings after round 11 this is the
last game will be showing from round 11
so these are the standings Carlsen in
clear first with seven-and-a-half
Kramnik now climbed all the way to
second place with seven points then are
announced six and a half's wheeler five
and a half we have gelfand with five
tied with Greece Chuck also with five a
vastly lunch with four and in last place
after losing this game to kramnik it's
team order Java with three and a half
points so that's the game and the entire
round 11 I do hope you enjoyed it all
the photos and a nice article by Peter
Dodgers will also be no there will be a
link in the description below so feel
free to check that out I really do
recommend it and I would like to thank
Matteo Steven Itsuki Stuart Clegg look
ring land a Gregory Quinn david marvel
and mickey grammatical and of course
alone padule Ian for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
so yeah I will I will probably only post
one video today and only one video
tomorrow and probably only one video on
Saturday as I will not be in Croatia for
for the next three days I'm visiting
Bosnia so I will try to make a couple of
videos and you know just publish them
one one each day so you do have
something to watch but if I miss
something I will I will definitely let
you know in advance so yeah once again
thank you all and I do believe I said it
maybe I haven't as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here so yeah
thank you and I will see you soon